these are my people you gotta [ __ ] the
one thing if I was Asian I'd make white
people bow I love that we everybody
thinks Bruce Lee stuff Bruce Lee wasn't
about being tough yeah Bruce Lee was a
light to immigrants before 1960 [ __ ]
hate everybody that was any other color
of a white you walked around like in the
shadows you walked around like Harvey
Weinstein in the shadows yeah after
Bruce Lee came he opened up the door to
immigrants immigrants had a voice
especially [ __ ] agent yeah agent like
[ __ ] with me now [ __ ] I got an
uncle who's got stars [ __ ] your world up
yeah agents had a way that's improve was
yes Lee was a hope for people black
people went crazy how many black people
eat do you ever see that think they
Chinese yeah can you rice with
chopsticks and [ __ ] when he infused into
the hip-hop okay [ __ ] them up those
black people got [ __ ] up by colorful
movies yeah if you grew up in the early
seventies you love bro my mother took me
to a Santeria dude because I kept saying
I'm moving to Asia
I had the shoes at the white shirt with
the buttons all dawg I had the white
shirt with the blue or black with the
shoes the heart used to [ __ ] burn
incense in my room and my mom would a
bowl of rice all I want is right you
can't eat rice any rice all day you
gotta eat me yeah yeah yeah eat rice you
show me a fat [ __ ] [ __ ] look at
me right yeah
[Music]